I work this place near Montana then the
blink of an eye just fire everywhere and
then charging out of these flames comes
this bear on fire was the most beautiful
and terrible thunder I've ever seen
I heard you guys had some slots
available you lost
got one slide open you know what we're
training for hotshots get to engage the
fire directly the SEAL Team six will
final fun if you give me a chance I
won't let you down
sooner or later the fire is gonna come
out get in our hometown been training
for over four years and got all our
hours all our qualifications but until
we're certified hotshots my crew won't
even be able to set foot on the line
a cold it wouldn't be easy
anyone Dear John Wayne
it's not easy sharing a man with the
fire
bigger
[Music]
would y'all to breathe in this beautiful
Vista because you're never gonna be able
to look at me otherwise see that pure
beauty again
- Gary's job
fire threatening homes
I said a daughter and I just really want
to get her one
the buyer gets past our line it goes to
our town burn over seconds away
as long as you can breathe survive
he's barely seen for the past few months
y'all Harris
no one could be prouder of his boys than
I am of you guys don't piece of me
coming in
[Music]